clearing chemical weapons then pulling
in the range you don't you have less
options we have been irresponsible we
sold arms to Iraq and trained them and
how to use them we sold arms to Iran and
trained them how to use them it was not
Iraq that brought the first nuclear and
chemical weapons into the Middle East it
was Israel the countries over there are
fighting and these engines and weapons
are deadly and dangerous and here comes
someone that that some people like less
is doing what others have done before
we've got thousands of thermonuclear
weapons over there ourselves we think
he's evil a lot of them think we're evil
we're not setting a very good example
one thing we could do would be to pull
back now is this a viable alternative or
is this some Looney tune peacenik saying
you know not go to war against saddam
hussein let me point out that in
November the Commandant of the Marine
Corps general Schwarzkopf the commander
of the troops in the Persian Gulf -
former chairman of the Joint Chiefs on a
four-star Navy admiral testified openly
and firmly to the Congress that it would
be a mistake to go to war against Saddam
Hussein at least now they said we should
wait a year or two to see if we could
not find some way to work sanctions on
the man to back him out of what he had
done in Kuwait instead for political
reasons George Bush overrode this advise
of top military commanders and proceeded
with his war now Henry B Gonzales has
that bill in there Bush did get
permission from the Congress to use
force to enforce the United Nations
resolution but they are promoting a bill
obviously it will not pass to prosecute
him to impeach him for inciting the
nation into war if we want to clean this
mess up we have to go to the - all the
real perpetrators of the incendiary
situation that we've got and and punish
them and prosecute them and hold them
responsible
and then we might have some chance of
creating a situation in the Middle East
where there could be peace now Israel's
position right now is very
understandable they are being they're
living under the threat of Scud missiles
any one of which could have chemical
weapons on it and this is not a pleasant
thing and when countries are in the
position of being shelved like that they
tend to want to go and shoot back
Israel has its own agenda and I am very
critical of some of Israel's policies
but since my position is that we should
resist war in the Persian Gulf
I applaud Israel for not in fact
plunging into the war as they might very
well have as they were tempted to do so
now however I think that Israel is is
and these are very intelligent people
living in a very you know on a thin ice
kind of situation in the Middle East in
Israel I've seen no indication that they
are really evaluating the long-term
outcome of their policies they are they
are vigorously supporting this effort to
suppress Saddam Hussein and get him
killed but it doesn't look to me like
they're looking at the consequences in
the Arab world in the Muslim world and
the anger and the rage that's being
bottled up right now it's guaranteeing
that we will have more Wars
sooner or later involving Israel in in
great violence and there are other
countries who do have chemical weapons
there and if this thing blows Israel can
nuke them and they can dump the chemical
weapons on Israel and it's going to be
very ugly in the Middle East and a 25
years to come because of the violence
that's being generated there right now
yes
like all the rallies the anti-war odds
would be fewer fewer people and most the
people are for the war what can the
movement do in the hall people I think
the peace movement is by and large doing
the right thing that is this question or
should it change its tactics I think
it's a measure of the success as I said
before of the establishment the military
establishment in creating a good war
that the peace movement would be wearing
yellow ribbons along with the police and
in Santa Cruz for example in in sending
support and warmth and cookies to the
Troops ie the Vietnam War was stopped by
the people in this country rising up in
a great rage and anger the peace
movement is is as Richard Meister the
actor said when I was talking in LA the
other day and he stood up and he was
arguing against me on this thing and
finally said well junk because he had
been a vigorous activist in the Vietnam
war against the Vietnam War and he said
John I want to feel good about this one
and well I'm sorry yes the peace
movement wants to feel good it's in the
instincts of people who want peace that
they don't want to feel rage and anger
but I'm sorry I don't see anything good
about this war there's nothing about it
that makes me feel good
nothing and there is not as much energy
coming from the peace movement as there
might be there's a crippling effect
because this is such a good war that
there seems to be something that will
buy off everybody you know are a lot of
people at different levels in this thing
they don't realize what is at stake I
have a friend in a different country who
has been of sending me books for years
he sent me the book called friendly
fascism he's a harsh critic of the US
and the US military machine but when
this war was launched and we're talking
about it over the phone he says I'm
going to have to take a pass on this one
because I'm going to support Israel
whatever happens so he's against war
he's against the US war complex and
everything unless Israel is involved
that's you know what has bought him into
this war so on this one he's taken a
powder he's put all of his books back in
the other room and he's going to support
this war while still condemning the US
and once this war is over he'll go back
to blasting us there is not a thread of
constancy it seems to me in his vision
of what's happening to the world and
there are other angles that are buying
other people out you know in different
ways and into this world I understand
those drives in those prerogatives but
we're paying a hell of a price because
we've restored war we've restored the
military machine and the world will pay
the price for it in the end yes ma'am
well the question is examples of
countries that have always or generally
tended to to avoid going to war famous
one of those is of course Switzerland
which has set itself up in the great
wars in Europe as a broker nation which
they all agreed they would allow it to
be neutral other countries that wanted
to be neutral weren't given that luxury
sometimes we're forced into it
Switzerland of course does merciless
economic exploitation of other countries
so you can criticize Switzerland at that
level I would really want to I've been
there and I've talked to peace activists
in Switzerland and conferred with them
including some famous women peace
activists but I really would hesitate
without some thought or a little
research to comment on the status of
women in Switzerland for example as
compared to here it is they cannot vote
someone told me yeah this is the details
that that I like I say I want to get
into to be specific about Switzerland
but I will I think your question is
leading into what I consider to be an
extremely important point I have always
been a feminist
despite also being a chauvinist in a lot
of ways but my my father taught my
brother and I when we were very small to
mend our own trousers because my mother
had her very demanding career and it was
his policy to support her very sincerely
and we all washed dishes we all cleaned
house we all mended clothes so that he
could do his job and she could do hers
and all of that profound feminist in
terms of equal rights and all of that I
observe and watch what's happening in
the world I've said many times early on
in my own growth that that perhaps the
answer since men have so bungled the
world and gotten it into the gym that
it's in now perhaps the answer would be
to go in the direction of women's
leadership however
[Applause]
however with that thought you
immediately run into problems the three
great women leaders of modern times took
their countries into war Margaret
Thatcher by Indira Gandhi and Golda Meir
now of course okay let me finish
of course the feminists will stand up
and say but they were forced to play it
by the men's rules however let me point
out some thoughts to you Phil Donahue
did a show in 1985 five-part segment the
human-animal one of which was on
aggression and he had these neurologists
from UCLA who went on and gave the
statistics that men seek violent
solutions ten times as often as women
women will resort to bloody violence
attempt as often as men and I thought
about this and I wrote him a letter and
I said I think you missed something and
those professors because when you're
talking about war yes on the streets or
in a house a woman is 1/10 as likely to
pick up a knife and stab women can do it
and they do it but attempt as often as
men but when you get into war you're
talking about a different dynamic
Margaret Thatcher was not picking up a
machine gun and shooting people down in
blood she was organizing her giant
family and for lots of centuries women
have been very capable of mobilizing the
family protecting the family fighting
for the turf arguing and even physically
resisting people are encroaching on her
family she was managing something and
orchestrating something very capably she
was not going to war herself now it is
true that men suffer from testosterone
poisoning this this is this is the
hormone of violence it relates to
violence there's no question about that
that's true it is actually generated by
certain types of physical activity and
in the schools for example where you
have big football teams where everyone
supports them and they get a lot of
support and their testosterone is high
there are a lot more crimes of violence
against women by football player
then for example in colleges where you
have a football team where the team is
de-emphasized and doesn't have the
support this is the testosterone factory
and the testosterone Factory at its
worst I came up with a theory for
whatever it's worth and you can all
scream and throw things at me if you
will but it seems to me I watch women
going through training and Marine Corps
boot camp and screaming and yelling the
same insane songs that what was that
song that they were singing in the
women's training uh something about a
bird flew in through my window on the
sill and I killed it I'm a lean mean
marine the same insane mad soldier songs
that the men were singing and it didn't
take much to get them to want to join
Pat Schroeder who's been out there in
Nevada with us protesting the nuclear
arms race in the Persian Gulf War was
giving speeches inside the Congress
saying that women must have the same
rights to combat that the men do
defending the rights to be killers it
seems to me that what we're dealing with
this may be an inane idea is that we're
all 85% people and we're all 15% men and
women there's a big common denominator
in us with regarding Wars and violence
and the ability to kill and fly planes
and strafe and bomb and rationalize
violence certainly women sure are taking
to it in the Gulf with great patriotism
and gusto and there's a 15 percent
factor that is different and I applaud
the difference and there is in that
factor somewhere nurturing and this is
where I come on real strong if we turn
to some source or engine in the world
for help it's not going to be to all
women because some what some women will
be perfectly happy to lead us to war and
fly the planes that drop the nuclear
weapons it's got to be to find and
isolate that 15% maternal nurturing
instinct and somehow use it to develop
the principle of nurturing our planet
and our resources and humankind
[Applause]
yes this this question is discussing
what's going to happen to the to the US
and to the world as the middle class
continues to shrink the poor continue to
grow percentile in in the society and
there they are called upon to support
and fight the war as the wealth is
shifted to the top the danger if we
don't reverse this policy of course is
continuing polarization that was set in
motion under the leadership of Ronald
Reagan and George Bush till eventually
in the polarization there is a great
gulf between us and then conflict and
then they apply the controls of the FEMA
and the world passes into a very harsh
and nasty world order that is the
direction in which we are going if we
don't reverse it somehow we have to find
the leadership and the energy amongst
ourselves to create a party that will
vote people into office that will begin
repealing these laws that will begin
reversing the flow that will
redistribute the wealth a little bit and
bring the people closer together so it
won't polarize into a very nasty
conflict confrontation that in fact is
evolving very rapidly right in front of
our eyes yes sir in the time
the question is is this Persian Gulf War
genocide are we deliberately targeting
civilian targets yes I would definitely
call it a genocide to the extent which
civilians are being killed I really
deplore this war first victims I said
where the Kuwait E's were invaded raped
pillaged and now are living on the
battlefield and the second victims are
the Iraqi people who have been are now
underneath the bombs there are lots of
people being killed by these bombs the
military is working very hard to give us
the impression that they're trying to
target military targets and then they're
being candid in saying nevertheless
there will be civilians hit I have not
seen evidence of deliberate targeting
large numbers of civilians just to be
killing large numbers of civilians we
don't know that would be bad politics
but we simply don't know they certainly
are careless certainly in Panama when
they were going in after Noriega they
managed to kill two thousand people as
we invaded that tiny little country they
were not careful and bombing and
strafing to keep it out of civilian
areas I believe that in time when the
truth is known if the media will report
it eventually we got the figures on
Panama from 60 minutes if the media will
report it I think we're going to find
that a lot more civilians were killed
than our smiling serious sober
articulate military spokes folks are
telling us right now
I'm truly concerned about that yes
the question is about CI manipulation
installation military governments in
Brazil and Chile in the 60s and 70s and
now that democracy has been restored how
effectively has it been restored and
there there is there is considerable
excitement in Chile now of the fact that
they do have a functioning democracy the
death squad activity is still taking
place but in a very small level people
can speak out they can promote bills
they can champion things and not really
worry about being disappeared the way
that that 30 or 40,000 of them were
after we installed Pinochet into office
I have the impression that the system is
working pretty good and the Chilean
people are a lot happier about it
Pinochet is still there he and his goons
are unpublished and this is obviously a
threat and something of concern my my
grown daughter is engaged to Chilean and
I've talked to him about these things an
educated man from the universities there
who lived through that horror and his
morale is up he is cynical about the
corruption that still exists it's not as
bad as it was before yes sir in the back
the question is how important do I feel
the CIA's role was and the downfall
destabilization the explosion implosion
of the Soviet Union that is happening
today and it's it's kind of a tough
question we haven't had any great
exposes of the programs we do know that
the CIA has been interested in
encouraging this process it clearly
benefits the United States to see the
other superpower broken down the other
side of that is there is a tendency to
overrate the power of the CIA on the one
hand I lecture and try to expose all of
the activities it's done to destabilize
the world to make so many people suffer
on the other hand the problems that the
Soviet Union has were 70 years in the
making an economy and before that an
economy that has been repressed the
people that have been repressed the the
major energy of that society and greater
proportion siphoned off into the
military it came into the arms race from
World War two if you read Daniel Yergin
s book shattered peace the Soviet Union
really on its knees at the end of World
War two we were soaring it was not a
fair competition if we were competing
with them they had lost
I forget the figures 20 million people
killed there were 70,000 villages had
been razed they had lost 500,000
railroad cars for example the industrial
base shattered as the armies had fought
over it
cities had been under siege for several
long years with incredible disease and
suffering and repression tremendous
traumatic scar on the country and they
were picking themselves up from that
with a motto of never again ie they
would build up they've been invaded four
times in history by major armies from
Europe coming down and sweeping across
and they just said never again so they
set out to pay any price to develop an
army and a nuclear capability that
nobody could invade them with impunity
in the future the result was that the
Soviet people paid a tremendous price I
mean Safeways forget it to buy a pot
roast if you
having someone to dinner you you know
you and this is before the recent
collapse where the conditions are so bad
now when I visited in 85 you would have
to stand in line for hours if there was
a pot roast there for you to buy when
you got there tremendous sacrifice by
the people to support a very essentially
corrupt military industrial machinery to
reverse that just to wave a wand over it
and say you're now free and capitalism
will prevail and we will prosper it just
doesn't work that way there's a sense I
talk to people of course have access to
I talk to famous economists and people
around about it people writing books on
it one of them told me that the Soviet
Union the people had been sold kind of a
bill of goods that that capitalism and
profits were a magic word and he said it
reminded him he said he'd written a
paper he had quoted Woody Allen who had
said he had been forced to study violin
all his life and he finally gave it up
when he was in his teens when he
realized he didn't know which end to
blow on I mean you have a system where
they declared freedom of the press but
one government agency controlled all the
paper and ink and then very quickly as
things got tight Gorbachev said you know
we have an open society we have a
president and then he pulled on to the
presidency dictatorial powers that
George Bush would dream of and and then
the KGB has now been restored to full
strength and the military and they
withdraw on the freedom of the press and
the reason that they're getting so tough
is they cannot give to the Soviet people
the goods and freedoms that the Soviet
people expected glass nose and very
stroke Oh would would bring the CIA
didn't do all of this to the Soviet
Union I'm sure they're in there when
they can you know gigging a little bit
here and there to urge people along into
the fragmentation of the thing they
probably have representatives in
Lithuania and Latvia for example nudging
the process along but I doubt if they're
really big players in that giant dynamic
of what's happening they're back to this
side yes sir
to take the last question first no I'm
not a Marxist I've struggled for a long
time to try to figure out what I am
since I left the agency I can't find a
label that fits and certainly not a
capitalist I don't have any capital I
was talking to a Welsh filmmaker who
took me to Havana to try to do a film
about the Cubans in Africa when that was
an issue in 1978 we were talking about
this and he said he said you're talking
about the good people of the world my
basic philosophy that I worked out in
college when frankly I found that
Christianity as I had been taught had
some flaws because I was taught that
everybody who didn't agree with me was
going to burn in hell virus for all of
eternity and that seemed a little harsh
and so I came out with my own philosophy
which I would probably describe as
humanism
some people say Neel humanism and I get
confused real easy I just call it
humanism people have to be at the bottom
and their interests and right and the
broadest health of as many people as we
possibly can has to be the driving force
and key principle of any system that I
will really commit my soul to yes
oh yeah South Africa of course has
maintained close ties with the United
States economic weight South Africa and
Israel they've been working at an
accommodation and modifying the
apartheid laws there's some there's
obviously deep monstrous problems living
in Africa the 15 years that I did and
working there with the CIA and visiting
South Africa and keenly aware of those
problems and the sea I by the way has a
longtime historic commitment to the
white South African security services
they they are making progress they have
released Nelson Mandela from prison they
are repealing some of the laws and I do
applaud but I think that the move now to
repeal the sanctions is premature I
think that that would be unfortunate for
them to leap to do that until you really
do achieve one-person one-vote in the
country and come up with some kind of a
leveling effect it would seem to me that
the new world order is not going to have
as a fundamental principle to people of
any country including the people of
South Africa I just cannot see George
Bush getting real worked up about the
plight and inequities of the lives of
blacks in South Africa when he is so
insensitive to the lives of the poor in
this own country yes in the red in the
back
the question is government FBI CIA
surveillance of student leaders comment
what you would have to do to attract
such hostile surveillance or interest I
would say that if you're 20 years old
and you do not have four files on you in
some government offices you're not a
responsible citizen of the world the
fastest instincts the control instincts
of the police their rationales now mind
you I would not want to live in a
society that had no police it's in the
nature of human beings that people would
get very ugly and abusive and it would
be a very difficult place to live in and
I would have to go around carrying a
weapon like Bogue Rights does and I
don't think I'm as good as shot as I
used to be and I'd rather not have to do
all of that I'd rather live in a country
that you had a police the trouble is
policing the police and kidding keeping
them from getting selective ideas that
they have the right to persecute for
example as the FBI did the civil rights
movement Martin Luther King and the deep
south finding the FBI participating in
the establishment of 50 KKK chapters for
example finding out that the FBI
director J Edgar Hoover was a compulsive
gambler gambling every weekend and two
vacations a year and mob casinos and
losing money and coincidentally having a
policy of not prosecuting or persecuting
the mob he said they were not a problem
in our society of finding out that this
man who dominated our National Police
Organization for so many years was was
homosexual which of course is his
business he had a live-in lover from
first a couple of three decades but he
viciously destroyed the lives of other
homosexuals and there you get into
someone who's twisted now this you get
the heritage of that organization that
he created
and it is out there with a policy that
is known it feels it has the obligation
and the right to penetrate student
groups and build files and they're quite
energetic they're not as pervasive as
you might think they just don't have the
budget they can't have two million
people working for them but they go in
and they recruit someone in groups and
say go around and tell us what these
people are doing and take photographs
and it's just very simply as I said if
you are active at all you're going to be
in their files I would be very
embarrassed if I found I was not in
their files it would really mean now
this is scary but I have urged people
before to go home tonight and take out
your dictionary and erase the word safe
and secure just scratch them out
altogether those words do not pertain to
a world that's polluted with 60,000
thermonuclear weapons and controlled by
people with the objectives that these
people now have on this world and what
we're doing to the environment of this
world there is no safe and there is no
secure don't pretend there is this is
what Helen Caldicott means you will feel
better if you get to work on the problem
because there is nowhere to hide the
planet is too small now the only
solution and it's a tough one we are
heading towards an extincted situation
for warm-blooded life unless we change
and there's nowhere to hide yes the
other one in the red
just very yeah very basically in Angola
the CIA is continuing the activities to
destabilize the country that I myself
helped to set in motion in 1975 arming
Jonas Savimbi I was the one that flew in
and recruited him into our program in
1975 and put him on our payroll for a
while the Clark amendment had it
suspended what we were doing and the
South Africans were doing it for us and
then President Reagan repealed the Clark
Amendment and now since 1987 I think it
was we've been back in there legally
giving him arms giving him missiles with
which he shoots down passenger planes
and admits that he does it and the
result is continuing instability in
Angola it continuing suffering
continuing huge allocations of resources
into the destabilization of the country
in the defense of the country into the
rebuilding of the country it's a country
that we have designated as a permanent
permanent designated enemy and until the
government is overthrown or there is
pressure from the public to release the
country from this this enemies list of
ours I think we will probably continue
to brutalize it the Soviet Union as its
losing its resources in collapsing into
economic chaos has less resources to put
in on the other side however Angola is
an oil country and it's been buying most
of the arms from the Soviet Union and my
sense we are by the way as you notice
drifting into Cold War - and it's my
concern that we will probably find
ourselves with the Soviets continuing to
arm Angola and us continuing to
destabilize it barring a miracle for the
Angolan people I feel very sorry for
that sorry for them
and with a sense of personal involvement
since I helped set that program in
motion all those years ago yes or int
there's a dark spot in there but I can
see a Hinda
yeah this is a good and enormous ly
timely question because George Bush was
all of the signals were that they would
bomb for another month or so the Iraqi
army and Kuwait and then Saddam Hussein
said himself our there was a signal came
out that they might withdraw from Kuwait
under certain circumstances and
immediately George Bush moved up the
date instead of months it would be a
matter of days before we would engage
the ground war because they want a
violent solution then Gorbachev steps in
and starts organizing a peace initiative
and it's not very mystifying why he's
doing what he's doing he has horrendous
problems in the Soviet Union which he
cannot solve either he is brought on
himself dictatorial powers and people
are protesting calling for his
resignation countries are breaking away
the Soviet Union is threatening to
descend into chaos with his armies or
the central armies fighting armies in
the different Republic's civil wars and
chaos and secessions he desperately
needed something to give himself some
energy and so that um he steps out as
the peace negotiator of the Persian Gulf
War what they're going to get out of it
in addition to his distracting the world
and the Soviet Union from the problems
if if he succeeds is keeping their
client state Iraq has had long ties with
the Soviet Union alive keeping it from
being invaded and overrun and broken by
the United States winning the friendship
of the Arab world that the United States
is now bitterly antagonized
unfortunately this is going to lead to
cold war to where they are on one side
and we are on another and an inflamed
situation in North Africa in the Middle
East you notice this has been very
frustrating to the white house and a
bush administration because and they've
been open about it they would look very
bad if they launched this ground war and
we started taking body bags while there
was a serious peace proposal on the
table they want a violent solution but
on the other
and they're under enormous pressure from
the people in the coalition and other
countries in the United Nations and the
world order that he's brought together
to accept some kind of a compromise that
will save all of the massacre in the
desert so what George Bush has done is
said he would give Saddam Hussein until
tomorrow at noon
- totally capitulate and promised total
withdrawal and begin the withdrawal with
no strings attached
or we will launch the ground war and I
personally am sitting here holding my
breath hoping that that the pressure on
George Bush will force him to moderate
his position and it's a time Hussein
will back out what Saddam Hussein has to
get out of this by the way as if he is
permitted to withdraw his army intact
then he will be he will have an army
back in Iraq with all the damage done to
society and he will be a major player
still in the Middle East George Bush's
interest is that he has this army cut
off in the desert he can destroy it it
won't wipe out the Nash the Republican
Guard but it will wipe out about half of
Iraqis forces and tanks and artillery
and all of that so he has a strong case
for wanting to cut them off isolate them
and also he wants to blood the United
States getting us worked up the war this
is not a man by nature nor nor is it in
his interest just to neck in the
backseat of a car he needs to consummate
the thing with a violence and blood the
United States and grieve the loss of
some soldiers in order for us to be
truly restored as a warring nation yes
sir
this is a question about Israel's role
in this where I've referred to it
obliquely
and I hasten to say that I am NOT it is
not my forte the study of the Middle
East I'm an African astonished uh deed
Central America in the 80s I'd begun in
the last eight months to read into the
Middle East I have been there before
since I was eight years old a few times
but I would not be qualified to really
speak for all the subtleties of Israel's
position and I can guarantee you that
anything I say will piss someone off
that just goes with discussing Israel in
the Middle East I would I would say
quite obviously just an observation
Israel has for a long time since it was
formed worked very hard and very
successfully to create a lobbying group
for its interest in the United States
and it has been very successful this is
one of the strongest lobbying groups in
the United States there is nothing
outrageous or unfair about this
everybody is trying to lobby for their
interests in this country
they've just perhaps been more
successful so the United States has
given Israel a lot of aid it has helped
Israel create a force an army which it
feels quite frankly will tend to do what
it calls stabilizing and representing a
certain aspect of its interests in the
Middle East but Israel is not in a
position to represent all of the US
interests in the Middle East we have
interests in Saudi Arabia and Kuwait for
example where they're investing billions
of dollars in our economy not in their
own countries but in our economy of the
oil money and selling therefore having
to sell them military equipment and
things that makes Israel uncomfortable
so there's definitely a tension between
the two countries attention between
Ronald Reagan and Israel attention
between George Bush and Israel it's it's
his great pride of accomplishment in the
New World Order and the coalition is
that he brought together certain Arab
states and other middle eastern states
including Israel into one coalition and
held them together through a month of
violence to get deeper into that subject
we should get
mana periods it was much more of a
scholar of Israel if you will permit me
I want to take one more question the
young lady in white and then I'll get
back to this side coming through the
middle George Bush's involvement in the
iran-contra scandal is pretty well known
actually he was the most active perhaps
vice president we've ever had he had
connections in contacts from his CIA
days he had his son down in Florida he
had personal contacts with people in the
in the Cuban exile movement and then
people in the Contra infrastructure I
can give you two three specific examples
for example of the energy that he had in
the contra program when the CIA itself
was balking the pros in the CIA were
refusing to work in this thing because
they saw it as illegal and sick and
would get them in trouble and William
Casey was wiring around with with Oliver
North and with George Bush you know
running wires around the central engine
of control in the thing now three
examples come to mind for we know he
flew down to confer with Manuel Noriega
in about 1983 he was involved in trying
to set up the Black Eagle resupply thing
to the Contra from the south which
Noriega eventually balked on we know
that he had direct contact
communications from Felix Rodriguez who
was placed in Hilo Pongo and El Salvador
flying planes against the Salvadorian
rebels but also supervising the air flow
the Air Wing of arms from the u.s. to
the Contras in Honduras and Nicaragua
Rodriguez history goes back into Vietnam
when he was with Don Gregg who went on
to work with Bush in China and then
became vice President Bush's national
security adviser
Felix Rodriguez was was reporting
directly to Don Gregg about the
management of the Contra program we know
this because they were outside of the
CIA and they were using essentially
commercial communications and we got the
public telephone bills and he was
calling Don Gregg every day for advice
when
hasenfus his plane was shot down the
first US official who was notified of it
was a phone call to George Bush's office
to telling what had happened
we know that Felix Rodriquez received
money from the Medellin Colombian
cocaine cartel to fund the contra
operations buying access to the airplane
so the airplanes would fly drugs back
into the United States according to the
drug laundry million Rodriquez ten
million dollars to his knowledge were
funneled through Felix Rodriquez into
the contra program we also know that
they got Luis Posada Korea's out of
prison in Venezuela because as Felix
said we needed him and this is the man
who was responsible for blowing helping
to blow up the passenger plane taking
off from Barbados on October 26 of 1976
killing 73 passengers on board a
terrorist and airplane bomber who has
got out to work for Felix Rodriquez in
the program that was being supervised
from George Bush's vice president's
office directly we know that very seals
when he was caught smuggling drugs flew
up to Washington to confer with the vice
president's office to cut a deal that if
he would do activities and run errands
for the drug smugglers for the CIA
against that he would he would not be
prosecuted he could cut a deal and one
of the things he did was to land a plane
in Panama and and they would kick some
bales of marijuana off it onto the
runway to be photographed by satellite
and Ronald Reagan was able to show these
pictures to the public claiming that
they were in Nicaragua claiming to prove
that the Sandinistas were smuggling
drugs which they were not now how bad
was Bush's involvement by the
iran-contra scandal broke in late
October early November of 1986 in the
winter of 87 and through into the winter
of 88 conservative columnist were
writing that George Bush's political
career was over the cause of his
involvement in the iran-contra scandal
they knew what had happened and they
said this man cannot survive ie to keep
the Reagan Revolution going and their
gains they were going to sacrifice him
because he was too dirty and you can go
back if you like it's fun project go
down and go through the films in the
library and just flip through them and
read the columns and you'll find them in
there in the winter of 88 during the
year of 87 then to their surprise in the
spring they began to see he would not
resign and I was saying in my lectures
then that if he failed to achieve the
presidency would probably go to jail if
he didn't pull onto himself the
protection of the presidency probably
the dirt would come out and he would be
prosecuted but that's moot because he
did succeed in capturing the Republican
nomination once it began to look like
the public would buy him then the
establishment got onto his bandwagon and
began to promote him and then the energy
mounted and he went whirling into the
presidency with with Dan Quayle
following him around to fulfill the role
of making him look tall and articulate
let's let's take it is late and we have
to close the building and my voice is
breaking let's take three more questions
and then we're just going to have to go
you've been trying very hard sir
yeah this one is a really big important
subject Oliver Stone is making a movie
about it right now in Dallas I have the
great privilege to have a very small
part in his production of this film
he's also bought Jim Garrison's book on
the subject and he's very close to Jim
Garrison and it's quite moving story the
last time I talked to him they had Kevin
Costner to star in it although they
haven't announced that and I don't know
if that's true or if it's a rumor they
are putting together what should be with
his magic touch very powerful recreation
of what happened
and we would you know obviously we would
need three hours to go through the whole
thing I have tried to read up on it the
best book on the subject that we have
out now right now I wouldn't say it's
perfect but it's the best it's crossfire
by Jim Marrs
summarizing in a nutshell there is not
any possibility that there was a lone
assassin Lee Harvey Oswald was not on
the sixth floor of the Book Depository
when the president was killed the rifle
that they attributed to him did not do
the killing there was a plot to kill him
as Fletcher Prouty puts it we know how
to keep presidents alive in that case
because so many people in the power
structure wanted him dead they withdrew
the protection and let him be killed it
was a military ambush there were three
firing stations in my mind military
expertise I would testify in court as as
an expert witness I would say that there
were at least 12 people involved in in
the action itself it was a
military-style ambush I can show you
that 8 to 10 shots were fired there were
2 stations from behind and one from the
front carefully timed carefully planned
and totally brass broad daylight a
military ambush the cover-up went into
effect immediately
J Edgar Hoover obviously had some prior
knowledge but
before the Dallas police could have
identified Lee Harvey Oswald he called
Bobby Kennedy and gave him Lee Harvey
Oswald's bio and said he was the killer
we know that the mob and others there
were police reports that that in the mob
and in some right-wing organizations in
Florida that the president was going to
be killed with a high-powered rifle and
a patsy set up to take the fall and this
is exactly what happened in my own
estimation and this gets into less of an
expert witness but just my own reading
and reconstruction of what happened a
lot of people read into this say
renegades did it but they were
definitely associated with the CIA the
Mafia and Cuban exiles I think we can
make a case that would definitely stand
up in court if we could ever get this
thing back into court to that effect the
renegades were CIA operatives who are
working out of the JM wave station
running military activities into Cuba
and then they turn the guns on the
president in the United States because
of the collective rage against him the
question gets to be then did the CIA
High Command have any prior knowledge
did they plan it did they order it did
they have a prior knowledge of it I
believe there are thin indications that
they did but there's not enough that you
could cite it as solid evidence in court
my instincts see they had created the Zr
rifle assassination unit under William
Harvey who hated the Kennedys who had
clashed with the Kennedys and he was
running we have his handwritten project
outline because they didn't want a
secretary to type it setting up the
cessation unit saying it has to be
criminals have to be recruited to run
the activities and case officers who are
comfortable with criminal activities
have to manage it and this thing was set
up and he had he had clashed with the
Kennedys in a violent way over the Cuban
Missile Crisis well that god this is so
complex it's hard just to assert it but
well the President Kennedy was trying to
get the missiles out of Cuba and
bluffing World War three nuclear war
with the Soviet Union
but wanting to resolve it bluffed him
not wanting to go to war William Harvey
was jamming killer teams into Cuba to
provoke the war to provoke the fighting
and this was a pirate thing outside of
policy by a madman down in the sea is
assassination unit afterwards Bobby
Kennedy found out what had happened and
they broke Harvey and exiled him to the
Rome station and eventually he died of
eating beef and steaks and drinking too
much but at the time his rage against
Kennedy and his propensity for killing
and this unit's activity and then the
threads and indications that we have I
would say somewhere from that group or
the people that worked under him or with
him with Cuban exiles with the Mafia and
we have a lot of details of the
overlapping activities with the Mafia in
this thing they are the ones who
actually put the shooters in Dallas and
polar triggers yes they're in the red
[Applause]
well I'll give you some suggestions and
I don't mean these to be radical in
terms of specifics you know I don't know
where you live and what your your skills
are in talents in that sense whether you
should join this type of a group or that
but one thing I I had to teach myself to
read these books when I left the CIA I
had been reading cables but mostly
running operations and reading fiction
for fun I had to teach my mind to read
in order to master all of this stuff and
come up with the observations that I
come up with I would suggest that you go
home and unplug your television set with
a pair of scissors
[Applause]
it's it's an enormous amount of fun when
you're tired it's addictive and you're
being fed lots of illusions and
fantasies and fun things that will
distract you from reading and informing
yourself if there's a television around
you will not converse with people and
share ideas and information and grow
there's always somewhere you can go to
watch a tennis match or a football game
if you want to as a special event you'll
enjoy it more you can get your news and
information and CNN is such a champion
of the truth anyway you can get it from
other sources set yourself a habit of
reading start with newspapers and
journals share articles with people
practice reading and then sharing the
information with as many people as you
can travel with when you can because
it's enormous ly growth 'fl to travel go
to countries I went for example in all
of my different travels I went to
Vietnam to see what we've done there I
went to England to go out and spend the
afternoon talking to the women at
Greenham Commons you know that we're
doing their protest I've tried to go
everywhere I could on my limited
resources it's not easy but it's
tremendously growth 'fl and you just
feel a greater sense of the universe and
the world when you sit down with
concerned people in London or in Sweden
or in in Hanoi or in an island in the
Caribbean or wherever it's a tough one
over the LES but the key has to be that
kind of an approach reaching out broadly
to people all the way across the world
it's the only way I see that we're going
to be able to turn this thing back
enough people deeply concerned I had an
interesting discussion and I don't mean
to get into esoteric interpretations and
everybody has different personalities
but I had a small clash with one of the
security officers in the airport in San
Luis Obispo he didn't know me it was
nothing personal but he was he was
following people around and you would
try to by you know get a cup of coffee
over here and he would say you had to
carry your suitcase over there and then
carry it back because you shouldn't be
separated from your suitcases and then
he got kind of outrageous and so I stood
up to him and told him he was not doing
his job properly and that there was no
threat since I was here and you know my
suitcase was 6:00 in the morning and I
was tired but nevertheless and then a
gentleman got up and wanted to fight me
he was threatened to hit me I think he
was martial arts or something because he
was not very big but he ordered me to
apologize and threaten me and so I stood
literally nose touching nose with him
it's the way he put himself telling him
that he should back down that it was my
business and he was interfering and if
he wanted to miss his plane and me miss
mine you know then we could spend the
morning talking about this but that he
should sit down then I went over and sat
down with this officer and talked to him
about how to do his job of watching for
security things without becoming a Nazi
and abusing people and bullying people
in disrupting their lives now we were
discussing this and Santacruz later and
a peace activist said I'm a hard-nosed
you know that I was being a source of
friction but I and lord knows I do not
say that I'm you know I'm all wisdom or
anything but my thought is this I
disagree with the Bible on the point
that you turn your other cheek when
someone hits you because I guarantee if
a bully hits you and you turn your other
cheek he'll hit it too and what I
believe I don't believe in hitting back
but I believe when someone hits you you
very firmly and reasonably tell them
that it's wrong to hit that they
shouldn't hit that they should find
another way to do business
and if they do hit you a second time you
tell them again but that's not the
proper conduct because it's clearly
demonstrated throughout history that if
you let people steamroll you especially
police and they get the sense that they
have the right to bully people and shove
them around they'll do it
if they get feedback and protest
vigorous firms sane mature feedback then
they have to cope with it and they'll
pull back I think this kind of approach
the people in government if we roll over
and say it's inevitable then they win by
default
we have to stand up to them in every
form you can think of
and reason with them now I'm sorry for
the others it's getting so late but that
the lady in white has been trying all
night to speak and I'm dying to hear
only the question is about the state
defense forces and the neo-nazi camps
that is bringing up all over the country
and do I have a comment and only the
very obvious comment that this is very
definitely a manifestation of the the
instincts and principles that President
Reagan Governor Reagan worked to
inculcate Bush a little bit less petty
and obnoxious about it but Ronald Reagan
had a real affinity for such madness and
these things are grassroots madness this
is a dangerous element this is where
you're taking the worst kind of people
and they're being encouraged to get
together and rehearse war rehearse
machine-gunning people rehearse imposing
their will on people I see it as a very
dangerous thing very much a symptom of
the times of what's happening of what
we're heading into very much part of
what all sane people have to calmly
maturely and determinedly put the brakes
on this could go on all night but it
can't go on all night I've got to speak
again in San Diego at noon tomorrow and
get up at 5:00 to get there at the
airport thank you very much
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
Oh
is there someone can drive can we get
out of here
fairly quickly yeah